we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p a lot of
feedback from my interview earlier this
week with former trump foreign policy
advisor carter page here is one
voicemail that really represents what
the consensus seemed to be about that
interview take a listen to this hey
david in the dictionary i looked up the
word obfuscate and there's a picture
next to it of carter page that's the
only thing I learned from that interview
he was very indirect and dishonest and
he looks like a weasel of that
photograph of his all the Republicans
look this honest maybe we should make
our decision about who to vote for based
on whether they look at dishonest or not
good night yeah I don't know about
voting for people based on their
physical appearance but that was the
consensus about the Carter page
interview which was that he seemed to be
obfuscating he seemed to be very very
slippery was a word that came up time
and again and yeah I mean when I just
say to him did you meet X person in
Russia and he takes seven minutes and
asks me about the Boston Celtics that
doesn't exactly inspire confidence that
this guy's is being super upfront
there's one other thing which I this is
just a weird sidebar but people noticed
that he wasn't on video we only had
audio from Carter page there was this
whole lead-up to the interview where we
explained where a TV show we do
interviews with via Skype video and he
said I don't have Skype and I don't want
to download skype I can't do it we've
got to do audio I'm going to call in he
ended up calling in from a phone number
associated with Skype and we didn't call
him out on it I haven't even mentioned
it to him but it was extraordinarily odd
and it made me question whether people's
even up front with us in the lead-up to
the interview you be the judge we have a
great bonus show coming up today we're
going to talk about some never Trump
errs who are considering supporting
Democrats in the midterms and even
potentially working for Democrats in the
2020 presidential campaign we will talk
about whether that makes sense for them
whether it's a good thing for Democrats
and much more we will also talk about
the possible first u.s. servicemember
remains being returned to the United
States
by North Korea
and we will discuss whether this is the
start of Kim jong-un potentially keeping
his word about those promises that he
made and then lastly on the bonus show
another tax cut that will overwhelmingly
disproportionately monumentally benefit
the very rich suggested or being
considered by the Trump administration
this one is the capital gains taxes and
the way it would be achieved is by
inflation indexing the cost basis for
investments subject to the capital gain
in tax if that sounds nuts to you I will
explain it to you in detail on the bonus
show which you can get access to by
becoming a member at WWE pakman.com or
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show